so we now have a challenger for Magnus
Carlsen and so I decided to pick a game
of his from his last World Championship
match I'll be honest it's not a
spectacular game however it does look
into his style it's Magnus of style when
he plays a lot of times he takes
advantage of small mistakes a little he
likes to go for positions with a little
bit of an edge and there's a lot of ways
to go wrong you have to be pretty sharp
so whoever's playing him in the World
Championship match has to defend and and
and be very precise in my opinion to
have a good chance so this is a game
from the last World Championship match
against the Vishy Anand it's the fourth
game of their match they were tied one
and a half apiece and Magnus was white
and he went for his typical small edge
type of position not super theoretical
but I'm going to be asking a lot of
times during this during this game guess
the move or predict a move or I want to
hear some suggestions because or often
will be a lot of ways to to go wrong and
the game changes dramatically
so efore c5 Magnus is white Vichy black
net f3 e6 so I think black is playing
play the timing off the slain with 96
next move that was a guest that was
fashionable back then and Magnus as he
does often side steps and plays g3 a
sideline in 96 Bishop g2 d5 and this is
awesome theory he takes d5 this isn't
quite like a Kings Indian attack you
can't play d3 or something
he takes d5 he takes d5 and castles it's
just an easy to play line as white
black plays Knight f6 developing and d4
and I think both players were aiming for
this position but a guy like magnus is
not complaining about the structure
because we're very close to an isolated
pawn position if black takes on d4 right
here he is left with an isolated pawn
which is requires some serious handling
it you know most people are more
comfortable playing against an isolate
upon black play Bishop e7 I'll just say
I'm taking on d4 not ideal to just help
like at that night there and Bishop d7
is not a bad move because white can take
advantage of it by trying to win the
temple rook e1 check or something it was
like moves like Bishop e6 and black gets
very active with this Bishop on c5 so
it's not necessarily a benefit for white
to win that tempo I can give an example
night g5 and you're just ignore it in
castle and there's these discovered
checks against f2 coming if you go
greedy and try to take that pawn on u6
the bishop is good on c5 so Magnus plays
Bishop e3 now he's starting to take on
c5 so now pawn takes d4 Knight takes d4
and Bishop g4 why is it move like Bishop
g4 played I mean is it really gaining a
tempo or is it actually giving like can
white just play f3 here or something or
gain a move why is such a like thin move
just the one move threat like Bishop g4
play so Bishop g4 is really developing
with with tempo because White's not
going to hit that back and play f3 that
so f3 Bishop d7
and Blackwell Castle but that yeah
that's that f threes not not looking too
sharp
so Magnus plays Queen d3 Queen d7 black
doesn't have to Castle right away why it
doesn't have some sort of rookie one
check or something here so has a little
bit of time Queen d7 if you don't if you
don't play Queen d7 right now why did
why did anon play Queen d7 before
castling can somebody show me a move
order benefit to that yes Arjun yeah H
exactly h3 can be played let's say you
Castle you can play h3 now and now the
bishop has to pick a diagonal but it's
nice to get the Queen and Bishop on the
same diagonal and now that's no longer
really a good possibility you'd have to
play Bishop d7 but Queen c8 is not as
attractive as Queen d7 the rooks aren't
connected white can play king h2 so what
black stands to gain more by playing
Queen d7 first because there's no way
white can stop block from castling so
that Bishop is quite annoying on g4 cuts
cuts off d1 Bishop h3 is a threat try to
trade off that fianchettoed Bishop and
so that's it that precise move order
Knight to d2 Knight c3 was also possible
just a developing move and we just have
a very simple Odysseys not not not a
very theoretical position but it still
has you know strategical ideas here but
you know usually Magnus is quite happy
to have these positions he has a chance
of an advantage that isolate upon can
definitely be a bad thing
can someone explain why 92 and 793 why
white did that specifically because
black has a nice laid upon what why 92
what what are you know me sir
exactly he said you know you want to
reinforce D for a good way to deal with
isolated pawns is the blockade them the
net on d4 is doing a good job there and
now the net on d2 can go to f3 or to b3
and reinforce that because if you block
it and isolate a pawn they can trade it
off so that's why white went 92 because
93 is also in the cards Castle Knight d2
f3 rook f e8 you know maybe the bishop
will go to f8 or something but that you
file is awesome there's going to be some
action there work everyone
Bishop d6 so now Bishop h3 might be
might be playable
does anybody is anybody tempted to take
on c6 and if so why I'm just curious
Noah yeah but that's that's probably
good usually you do wanna better to play
against an isolated isolated pawn but
the thing is Anand is doing a good job
here he's not trading off it would be a
big mistake for black to take on d4 that
just helps white y can then take back
with a knight and have the bishop on g2
doing something the more pieces on the
board I'm it's harder harder for white
to just play positionally against that
pawn there's tactics to worry about so
often when you have an isolate a pawn
you want to keep more pieces on the
board
Magnus place III he plays these natural
moves all the time just nothing special
but keeps attention as long as the
structure stays the same why it's always
the one trying to push because the end
games will be better for white so black
has to be sharp
Anand play to h6 and what I'm wondering
is he had the option of maybe getting
some position like Bishop h3 but there's
a variation even in this position
probably Bishop takes h3 Queen takes h3
and something like Queen f5 and just go
for that slightly better endgame if you
play like Knight g4 trying to checkmate
this move is really annoying with the
threat of Queen takes f7 check and
Knight g5
and Windex d5 is also a threat here so
there's a couple couple moves but
there's no checkmate for black so I mean
I think objectively black is supposed to
take on f5 and this is a sort of
position that is going to favor favor
white yeah so Allen has to be careful to
not create up too many pieces which is
why he's not taking on d4 so h6 just the
waiting move it's funny I move like 94
you didn't play it as well and here
yeah 94 would also be possible just to
try to get the pieces into the game
follow up with rook a to d8 play
actively although even here I tend to
believe white is happy to play this sort
of position but it's a bit it's a bit
messy it's a bit messy for sure but he
plays h6 asking white what's white you
know what are you going to do is wait to
improve your position here because it's
really annoying for white that this
bishop isn't in the game right now I
mean white really wants to provoke some
sort of Knight takes d4 and clarify the
position but it's not possible right now
Magnus plays Queen to f1 so that you can
play h3
what's a decent move for black after
queen f1 somebody play for black here I
have to ask one thing is anybody tempted
to play Knight takes d4 no that's very
good that's we have to avoid mistakes
that's exactly what he thrives on small
Knight d4 Bishop takes every trades
no 95 no anybody's in about 95 no 95 as
well makes life much easier for white
just trading trading pieces off you'll
be h3 now but makes it much easier to
figure out the position and start
focusing on d5 maybe Queen b5 next even
fact probably I play a move like Queen
b5 and just try to trade and leverage
that so yes
keep playing a move that keeps the
tension Queen f1 you played Bishop h5
but Brooke see it I can't complain about
maybe even Rick d8 as decent moves you
just have to not panic here kind of you
know keep the position h3
still plays actually there's no night g4
but it's like typical like you just want
to attach the test black box as long as
black is playing decent moves the
position is okay but or every single
move there's a couple moves that can
lead to annoying positions they haven't
been played yet so far so so far I know
it's been up to tasks you should g6 rook
a to d1 pretty self-explanatory there
make sure nobody's wanting the trade-off
pieces that will help white rook 88 just
getting the last work into the game
copying white but now you probably have
to come up with a plan for black pretty
soon those in this position that Magnus
finally decides to take on c6 what
caused that why why now why is why doing
Knight takes c6 now I'm not saying
because it's a good thing but you can
play c4 you can play this position what
he did was was definitely playable but I
mean here I think why it was waiting for
black to do something black has played
as many whites run out of useful moves
I mean White's played h3 brought the
rooks in the queen is on f1 there aren't
too many more waiting moves that make
any sense
you can play king h2 but that puts your
King on the same squares the bishop on
d6 he yeah so the question is like yes
for a low-rated player is that enough I
mean usually they say you need two
weaknesses so I mean even for four
magnets isolate upon it something but it
usually does need to find it a bit more
I mean it's not it's not that he wins
because I said upon it wins he wins
because he gets a good position because
I said upon and then they crack under
not because they're losing yet they make
mistakes once they're just in an
uncomfortable position so an isolate
upon itself is not enough you no matter
who you are but by the
you place the positions very well there
they're easier to play and then people
make more mistakes at compounds but it's
not the only factor don't if you have a
really good position and you see a way
to force an isolate upon so you give up
your good position to get isolate upon
no no no I'm not no no no don't don't
don't necessarily do that but why it's
kind of running out of useful moves here
rookie d1 was useful but now what you're
going to route Ricky - rookie - they're
all decide to play 96
what's plox obvious reply here B Tech c6
hope nobody's playing Queen takes c6 B
takes c6 it's no longer isolated still
not perfect pawn structure but it's an
improvement towards the center so now
the game transitions to a different
structure and now Magnus plays
accordingly c4 it's still a little bit
easier to play for white it's it's still
risk your pawn structure go black I mean
there's an isolated pawn in a7 c6 could
be weak but there's just more targets
why it's pretty defensive right now
Bishop c4 was played make sense just
challenge that fianchetto bishop okay
objectively the position has been equal
just he's trying to find find a way to
to make it a little a little bit of a
pull this Bishop to d4
play for black here guys Bishop d4
simp simple chest from why--just still
waiting fishing for for something ooh
thanks for the suggestion because that's
exactly what I want to go over trying to
trying to make a draw against Magnus and
the suggestion was Bishop f3 Bishop f3
rook takes e1 rook takes e1 and rook e8
that's not going to turn out well there
are a few different first of all first
of all if you were just to take this as
is 98 or Queen e8 white spider to
bishops open position clearly better and
you're going to draw this you're going
to suffer for a long time although I
don't think I don't think it's even you
know even quite isolated to isolated
pawns bishops open position much much
better for white and there's no way to
force force the pieces off so not good
the second hand you have to be willing
to defend this type of structure and I'm
not sure I don't know too many people
who like to play the structure this is
also unpleasant although you can hold
this it's you can torture you can
torture with King g2 just this is just
double isolated pawns on the file are
not good but the other line is better to
bishops that's so that is you cannot
just force the issue there unfortunately
that would be exactly where he is
technique in good positions is very very
very good I mean it doesn't have issue
there but two bishops know they should
have three big no no
any other moves guys just bishop before
these are almost that white can play
without thinking too much that's
something I don't if you guys to notice
not a very confrontational position for
the most part it's been natural moves
I think after Queen f5 probably I'll
just play with tempo Knight age for your
queen ass this be close to the knight on
f6 you're running out of squares you I'm
not sure you can play Queen e6 and put
your Queen and Bishop on the same file
if you have to start making moves like
this
the Queen is starting to get hunted down
a little bit although it may not be
something but I might even be quite
quite honestly I might even be a greedy
greedy guy and just take that pawn with
I might just take that pawn shamelessly
with the idea of rook e8 Bishop all the
way back to e3 so I'm not sure I don't
think I don't think you can do that
I think net h4 and whites now all of a
sudden better like actually better
just don't blender guys I'm playing I'm
pretending to be magnets just waiting
for mistakes
so Bishop b4 make sense
Bishop d4 how can this move be so strong
just we just find find a decent move for
black here
Knight age 7 h7 yes
Knight h7
might come to g5 but it's it's just you
know there aren't too many other
attracted was rookie six maybe was
playable I'm I'm not entirely sold on it
but I don't see something wrong with it
right away but night h7 no way to
blender with that and the night might
become a g5 there might be ideas a
Bishop f3 Knight g5
now Magnus decided to take on d5 I wanna
on a note c5 and playing these type of
structures is probably not a good thing
black would be very happy to close that
position and I'll probably start to
expand or play f5 or something but
closing closing the position isn't in
White's best interest d5 is more of a
target that once you play c5 you're not
really putting pressure anymore after c5
yeah well the idea would be the idea
would be to maybe make your own B 4 a 4
and B 5 because you have the past pawn
blocked and it looks like it's gonna be
blocked
well maybe not entirely maybe not if a
96 but it is comfortably blocked right
now sometimes people you know you know
they'll play a 4 B 5 try to do the
outside attack but yeah it's not it's
not the best net h7c takes d5 question C
takes d5 or Bishop takes d5 well C takes
is a passed pawn by isolated pawns or
usually passed pawns and people are
happy to get rid of them so it's a it's
a it's definitely an option there's no
definite option I think what Vichy did
here was quite accurate and showed his
he was up to up to task that day let's
see let's say C takes okay I'll play
Queen a6
let me show a typical position let's say
Bishop be a bishop c3 and I'll say this
position should be easier to play for
white we're starting to get the pressure
on d5 compared to before one piece is
being traded pawns have been traded and
that pawn on d5 looks a lot more
vulnerable than before there's more
tactics going on the rooks are very
effective on e 1 and D 1 it seems to me
like whites improve the position a bit
more just visually that you know that is
on h7 White's visible on c3 very nice
Square rook on d1 is doing something
clean on a6 he did Bishop takes d5 well
that was a nice move evaluated the point
on c6 to be better than having a pawn on
d5 I think I think it was correct really
I thought that last position is is
better for for white
now maybe I'll trade a pair of rooks
just one pair and play Queen to d3
now this position is still slightly
slightly preferable for white that's
because the pawn structure I think if I
everything else is equal which it kind
of is I mean at any moment if white once
you can probably trade off the bishop on
d5 but usually you need more than a
weakness to try to push so it's close to
equal maybe slightly preferable for
white if they go into a pure endgame
that's something but I don't think black
needs to allow that I was thinking maybe
Queen a6 again just to be annoying but
black is getting a ton of counter play I
was looking at moves like this and it's
just with with only one work on the
board things get a little bit Messier
after he's hanging I see why you didn't
do that he plays a bit safer Queen to d3
but in none of these positions has there
been option for black to trade
everything off and go for like that
drawing endgame or something if you you
know you have to maintain the balance
here if you go for something forcing you
still have to isolate the pawns on c6
and 87 night f8 transferring the knight
to e6 now tell me what one point Knight
g5 all right yeah net Knight g5 s Knight
g5 a move is there they should have
three or something like any other move
it's not g5 possible here yeah it just
trades off some pieces
it attacks h3 but yeah Knight g5
probably not while tempting and probably
playable so still white should be on the
good side of things
just after kingi - well we just have to
kingi - you're going to pull your Bishop
back to e3 and just put pressure on
black it's still not anything
spectacular but black is the only one
suffering here so 9f8 night h4
Bish's so night h4 is going to at night
f5 f5 square and you moves for black
your guys will play a good move for
blacker position starts getting a bit
trickier now after net h4 because that's
an aggressive move
there's quite a few ways to go wrong now
okay there's a few ways to go wrong here
but it plays a nice move actually Bishop
to e5 but already somehow okay I mean I
feel like whites white still you know I
think all of us would take white which
is what Magnus is dangerous you can take
like these basic positions that theory
says are equal but get a little bit of a
pull in equal position that the
computers won't to acknowledge but that
humans kind of will have troubles with
so Bishop e5 was played again you know
do not trade trading very you know very
bad getting it not very bad but
unpleasant I mean clarifying the
position like now something like Bishop
e5
this endgame should be should be
comfortable for white an online game
master per se but let's say Queen takes
Queen rook takes objectively speaking it
should be should be white with with the
edge here
maybe rook a3 a5 and trying to trying to
attack I mean put the pressure on those
double pawns maybe get that night to
attack but if you lose that a5 pawn this
is this is a very bad endgame maybe rook
d5 but okay it's not a nice not a nice
endgame so Bishop e5 was played now
Magnus had one move that I thought he
could have gone for
but so far like no moves that white has
played have been conceptually to our
this is just one of his games I just
want to test black and a well known
structure it should be five
offering a trade Magnus took on d5 here
and wanted to trade off pieces now I
thought this might have been the one
chance in the game or one of the chances
where your bit should be five take on
this we'll take c5 work 65 and f4 but
okay maybe Ricky and at f5 some position
like this that's what I was thinking
yeah maybe maybe white can play for a
little bit of something here
it looks better for white but the King
is not as safe on it's not that safe on
g1 or at least I'm not that happy to
trade everything off just went upon if
my king is really naked but just an
example I'll play king is a queen e6
something like rook d2 this is the type
of way white asked to play this play
keep the isolate upon keep the piece on
the board okay you can take this pawn
that's a good question why can't you
take that's a good way I can't you take
the pawn but I was just looking at this
position and I could see you know this
is this is a type of slightly better
position you can still aim for and have
very little risk as white why can't you
take on d5 that's the little puzzle not
saying it's a blunder but it hurts
white's winning chances queen takes d5
Queen b6 check attacking the pawn in the
king queen d4 and now and now you get
actually actually I thought there's
Ricky one but the Knights protecting it
I thought there's Ricky when I was about
to give up that doesn't work that
doesn't work so may I my oh oh
I was about to blunder I was like
they're both they're both the same idea
but massive difference I think I think
this is the issue and then game over so
that's a neat little tactic but some
position like this is still a little bit
better for white because of the
structure but yeah you didn't go for
that you went for just the pure endgame
this should be five sorry Bishop d5
Queen d5
okay Queen takes e5 here not Queen takes
Queen is not going going for this I like
how a nun played this game which is one
of the reasons why I'm showing it this
game has a lot to do more with the
defensive you know playing playing good
in a slightly worse position this this
staff this position also could be
suffering for for black that's it's he
evaluated the Queen's on is easier to
draw
Magnus plays b3 now just defending solid
solid move 96 bring the piece in I mean
keep in mind you don't want to just
blatantly trade Queens here because now
this might be a better version for black
if you get the rook really fast like
that so be 396 and Knight f3 bring the
knight back into the game now I like
like this part Queen f6
what did Magnus play here I think a lot
of you guys will play the same move keep
it simple Queen d7 is a losing move
just the just a simple move Kim G - just
Kim G -
rikiei Queenie to anybody here work to
xd1 trade works trade everything MacGraw
black is worse can you position what did
black play here if any moment you guys
see a variation anything black can make
a draw or like hold the position and
we'll look at that but I think there's
always a little bit of tension that's
what he tries to keep rook d5 you know
rook d5 do rook t1 c6 I think is worse
than d5 let's say this position
maybe some of the Queen d8 maybe but
it's also there could be some ways to
push this I've had but watch to rook d5
with a plan in mind so maintenance plays
rook takes d5 pawn takes d5 and this is
an interesting moment I was looking over
this and I was like well those pawns are
awfully weak on like a7 and stuff like
that does anybody you're tempted by
Queen a6 check s or Queen 86 I want to
play Queen 86 is anyone joining me
you'll play Queen 86 pardon me here with
me oh I almost caught one person there
okay okay you're right
Queenie 86 is bad most of about Queen b5
we'll just play Queen v 5 together right
because then we're threatening Queen d5
and with running Queen B a check anybody
playing Queen b5 with me here you are
okay that's good we got one guy anyone
else no okay well I got one person so
that's enough now I want to put Queen b5
I mean be nice and white did at a time
you would want to play this because
isolated pawns should be attacked your
whites king is very safe you could go up
on hunting but unfortunately the two
squares you want to go to run into run
into tactics you want to play you just
didn't pull your handle but Queen a6 but
okay it's still it's still position it's
still it's the little summit something
so night well if you don't have that 95
trying to get the pieces in
but I'm ninth oak the pawn on d5 instead
of leaving one on c6 because I mean this
is now a passed pawn there's they're
both isolated pawns but d5 is now a
passed I slip on so it's good and bad
but he you know you read that as you'd
rather have that than the bouncy six
Queen f5
the cute little move the queen is well
placed on f5 it's watching on e4 the
Queen whites Queen can't really go too
far because there's Queenie forecheck
Knight d3 anybody playing Queenie
forecheck anyone tempted by Queenie for
check here you still are wait giving
black a chance the longer Queenie 4
check probably not good Queen takes
maybe bring that Knight to e5 and we're
going to go to see sick we have the
outside pass pawn so it's still
preferable for white still not a clear
draw so still no rushing it still not
rushing it even when you're like oh I
almost called P straight off not not so
fast
hmmm d4 key for not played I wonder why
maybe Queen f3 d4 could have been played
I think why would try to trade Queens
off in this position do trade Queens no
no nice long it don't read Queens then
the net then nobody's messing up here I
think place Knight to d4 because you
can't play Queen e5 here or something
and you have to watch f3 well we see why
the D pawn is useful later on g4
whoa
Queen d7 now the point is there's a lot
of positions here where I on can
probably like play a position and
objectively it's a drawn but but he goes
for whatever is easier for him like when
there's all these different moves by the
position that you're kind of comfortable
with I mean maybe this is actually a
draw but yeah I might have to find some
precise moves but practically speaking
if you keep the Queens on the board you
retain perpetual possibilities you have
peace to support that pass bond whereas
with the Queen's off that pass pawn is
worse than outside the outside pawns for
white like so keep keeping Quinn's on
the board ensures it's a lot harder to
blunder
whoo mmm I think they're both very good
it's I think it comes down who's a
better problem Magnus might be a little
better visually played very good and
games in the candidates when he had good
positions visually played very well when
he had bad positions he played very
badly so his conversion was very good
but defense wasn't so good in the recent
candidates
so now it's like you're black okay let's
say in a perfect world white manages to
get his Queen on the Queen side tries to
go pawn hunting I'm just going to keep
my Queen in the center and whenever you
take on a 7 I'm going to start checking
you or something like it says you know
all these weaknesses will will tell
queenie 596 king g3
keep in mind you can still get a worse
position you play d4 here it's not not
that easy I might might still be drawn
but I might start putting a bit of
pressure as long as my king is safe but
he was playing for for the Queen Queen's
the whole time Queen b5 Knight f4
so in this position do you wanna trade
Queens this block absolutely not
absolutely not just double-checking just
double-checking good yeah this is what
happened I mean because he does win a
lot of games people do make a blunder in
the fifth hour of place except sometimes
your brain stops working and you do
something you know you're not supposed
to do Queen B 4 check King f3 no more
checks now players black here like it's
an option to passive defense here or
active defense passed pawn King position
black goes active and I'd say you know
if you play Queen b7 I think it's okay
but block the pawn should still be
should still be a draw but black was
keeping the Queens on the board I think
for some active kind of Lee plays quite
precisely here because he forces the
draw let's put it that way with not not
immediately but King King f3 I said that
deep on was wasn't there for nothing
because Queenie a check is a threat now
you're not playing Queen f8 d for right
away because the Queen on D 2 also
blocks the D pawn right you don't
necessarily have to do it
Queeny a check King age seven Queen
takes f7 any d3 anybody know okay that's
good no no d3 is that's good Queen d2 so
we get to your position Queen d2 is is
precise is precise but what that means
is you have to evaluate this position as
being down upon but no way for white to
progress progress with with that Queen
f5 check King here h4 I think the idea
is to by g5 and g6 exactly yeah look at
that Queen it like oh you don't okay you
don't want to play Queen takes a two so
we'll play d3 right
push right past pons must be pushed you
can play you can play any move you can
play any move
I think it still works just push the
pond what do you guys wave
I think d3 works as well so
everyone has a different way but yeah
quick so d3 I mean I think I don't think
I'm missing something
unless g5 works but I don't think it
does Queen takes a to Queen e6 this is
always played it was just the Drago but
the D pawn is way too dangerous I think
d3 does work but there were a lot of
possibilities for black to go wrong I
mean it looks quite easy to defensive
house but he read the position quite
quite well so it was a repetition in the
end but these are that positions Magnus
regularly goes for and the thing is he
just doesn't lose very much so he might
win this 10 percent of the time 15% but
that's still something I mean people
make a blunder in the middle game like
this is typical of his style why it's
always the one who is better why was
always the one who had the better
endgame and if you slip up in time
trouble you at the Queen's offer work
endgame you might be drawn but you'll be
suffering a bit and then people cracked
but in this position black didn't have
to suffer he always kept the balance and
practically speaking didn't have some
sort of you know defensive task here
kept the Queen's on the board that rook
to d5 is important though I think this
even here you can slip up usually even
trying to play this there are ways to I
think what would have had to trade
Queens you could have traded everything
off because I think if you don't trade
Queens off here as Queen d5 and I think
black is okay so I think Queen d8 could
have been possible could still be on but
you're on the worst worst side of it
whereas another variation I think Magnus
had to force the drawn the end because
of the D pawn so there's different ways
of doing it but
I wanted to look at this game because I
was looking at you know past World
Championship matches of Magnus to see
what he excels in and he doesn't win a
lot of games from the opening you just
just tries to grind them out and this is
this is a grind I didn't you know wasn't
successful but he still got something
from nothing like I don't think any of
the most of the moves are not beyond us
or require a lot of work necessarily I
mean he does have a lot of understanding
he's way better but you see he's not
going for the most forcing tactical
variations he just wants to get these
slightly better position so I thought
this would you know this is the type of
these are the type of games that Sergei
karyakin you'll have to be you'll have
to be playing a consistent these the
defensive level like this or better I
think to have a decent chance against
Magnus this fall because there's no way
to avoid these type of positions because
computers will just tell you this is
fine for you but you thought like humans
have a much harder time defending
defending these positions